yeah you trying quiet now no I lost my
best friend this year so it's still been
he thing for me I'm so sorry like you
made me think about it I'm so
sorry oh my God can we give him a hug
sorry I so the oh my God it's hard going
droke my
brother um I really appreciated his
honesty and vulnerability 1 hour later
we have West told you
at and then just like mildly
uncomfortable which is nothing against
him we'll start there to the yes the way
do you think women often find you
attractive
uh
yeah I like that short answer I
appreciate it he didn't try to be like
oh well you know like not really uh yeah
yeah hot people who pretend they not hot
just [__] Mak me sick it's like it's
like rich people try to pretend they not
rich meaning they got money like
overflowing from their pants like got
beautiful hair yeah shut up yeah stupid
so why why did you put him for I feel
like I saw his smile the smile was nice
he's tall and he has like really nice
hair and he's tan what are you looking
for in a man physically
um definitely someone who's tall taller
than me that's for sure definitely good
teeth says a lot about personal hygiene
if it looks like you haven't brushed
your hair in a day or two someone with
bad hygiene that's just immediately you
don't take care of herself and I don't
want to be near you I like Smiles I like
eyes and energy maybe like demeanor like
how they're standing I think blue shirt
needs to be second or because his his
face is really symmetrical I like eyes
second yep all the lightskin people just
getting [__] thrown up to the front
hey let's go let me just see yep yep
okay this one has Personality yeah he's
like unbothered I really like him look
at his shirt guys yeah it's giving
Shaggy from I really like him too Jack
is giving Jack is giving he's unbuttered
really he's really unbothered first
thing she going to complain about oh my
God like it looks like you don't
care our hygiene our hygiene I think I
got like a pretty nice face like my nose
was really like everyone says I got a
cute
nose sorry sorry hey listen hey you know
you want you want to B self-confidence
whatever you got to tell yourself how
did you feel during the physical round
uh I loved it I led when people are
judging me made me feel good even though
I wasn't at the top it was just like
yeah they get to look at me why does
this guy sound like he was invisible in
his childhood he like just look at me I
don't care if you think I'm ugly just
look at
him I don't it just sounded sad I love
it when people are judging me is that
I've never heard anyone never heard that
that is the first it was honestly good
for them they got to look at some beauty
over
here I'm not not used to hearing
delusional males like that but hey you
know what live your life your life live
your life but
no can everyone introduce themselves
name and what you doing yes uh I'm Kai
and I model I'm West I'm a student and
model I'm Andre and I run a tech company
is that an accent is that an accent yeah
yeah what do you think it is I have no
idea but I like
it I'm Jack I'm an actor and I coach
volleyball I'm Nick I'm a painter and a
I make furniture um what's everybody's
favorite movie everything every W once
okay that's a really good one tear with
the sun okay it's about um the war in
Africa How African nations go against
each other and um us forcan over save um
um I think it was a princess or King a
really deep one okay okay okay he seemed
like he was very nervous that nervous
energy was a little bit off-putting so
that energy just didn't match I'm going
to be that person what's your zodiac
sign yeah this episode is dry as hell
like they're all conventionally fairly
attractive but dry are you just asking
for son or
like oh my
dayso I hate it when Attractive people
try to have personality I'm Aries Sun s
Moon Taurus Rising oh my God okay should
we have something deeper like should we
go deep when's the last time you cried I
was watching a medication commer
for like back pain and this woman was
like in a hospital I was like [__] this
is so sad oh my God yeah so I CED
commercials
and I don't know why I don't like this
episode am I crazy you're not am I crazy
you're not something about this
episode's off what is it it's like 10
people up in here right it's not funny
not interesting it's 10 people 10
different people and it's the same so
you're like out of 10 people not one's
going to
no it feels like it's really Bland as
hell one says it's given they all say
it's given the funniest person is the
ugliest person and it's because they
think they're attractive so the delusion
is funny yes you know what I mean like
when someone's M and they're like I'm be
Hey listen how much confidence you want
that's your thing but it's funny to
watch on ph other than that the rest of
this is dry you got a bunch of models
you got people pretending they're into
like astrology [__] I don't it's just
dry yeah you try quiet now no I lost my
best friend this year so it's heart
thing for me I'm so sorry you made me
think about it I'm so
sorry oh my God can we give him a
hug I can't I can't I'm sorry something
about this episode just off to me bro
wait is that can we get give group hug
oh my
gosh I'm so
sorry nah n okay I'm going to say
something I'm going to say something bro
as I lose someone dear near to me last
thing I wanted a bunch of strangers
hugging me but he that's me that's me so
that's you know you know what grieve
however you got to do it
oh damn whose question was that no sorry
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding and
you oh mine was like I think last week I
think it at the movies I was watching a
movie okay the stupidest reason it's
Blue Beetle and had something to do with
family and I just made me cry so hard
that makes sense I was like damn I cried
like three times in that movie I think I
respect though y respect for GR
man respect for GR hey my for cry
respect dog respect put a little
respect like
a oh my God what's your body
count
okay my mom's going to watch this 13
okay not bad
10 I think i' you know I don't want to
think of each one as like a number so
yeah uh you filthy animal you filthy
[__] animal just say you don't want
to answer okay don't give some [__] boy
I don't want to think of each one as a
number it's like listen I don't discuss
that which is perfectly
acceptable question I want to keep that
private off his answer and a lost track
okay is a crazy respon I didn't I never
I never I never count I never like he's
like say I never kept track of this so
at the point I never actually count in
my head at the point like in my head
Miss I'm counting okay Nick you've been
reacting back then it's interesting what
what was your reaction when you didn't
want to think of everyone as a number uh
I would like to ask you when the last
time you got tested for anything was uh
hey hey why hey hey we got a hater in
the back listen listen listen if the
girl I'm getting involved we wants to
ask me when I last got take that fine
hey you shut the [__] up with you hey
you in the same line as me me that's it
you in the same hey that's it it's like
SD tests are readily available you go in
you get results 3 to 4 days later if you
go to a clinic or if you go to one of
the free spots like takes two weeks it's
not hard for people to get it done like
that's not even why you ask that
question insinuate this guy some [__]
disgusting SCD written filled animal you
know what's crazy is a lot of people who
don't think they need to DOD test cuz
they have a low body count end up
getting [__] naed by something
because they feel like they're in such a
safe environment but it just takes one
partner to cheat on you or for you to
trust the word the one person cuz they
told you they had a low body count let
me give you guys a piece of advice okay
doesn't matter what number somebody
gives you get a test done okay even if
they say their number is one or zero do
not believe a single word that comes out
of their mouth if you're about to sleep
with these people odds are you've only
known them for a few weeks or a few
months you don't know days you don't
know maybe they got didd maybe they got
cheated on or maybe they don't feel
comfortable or ashamed with certain
people or they don't want to count
penetration because it was only two
pumps or they use a like people have
crazy rules in their head you don't know
so my rule is I tell everyone their body
count don't matter none of that [__]
matters as them to get tested and see
the paper without any of that you don't
[__] know anything I had one girl who
was trying to tell me everything's fine
she was in a long-term relationship for
3 years and that was it I I don't care
get tested she like what you think I
cheated I I don't know what y'all did I
don't know what he did I'm not saying
you're a liar I'm saying you may not
know turns out she got tested and I was
right I'm just
saying just be safe that's it you want
to talk about actual sexual
damn that's awkward after I mean it's
fine yo if someone no no no no no I'm
that's not what I'm saying but if
someone was you say that to someone
right someone's giving you lip about it
yeah and you're like I don't know I
don't I don't know you might not know
and then finally you're right that's
awkward
after I just think that's the most
responsible thing to do but people
saying stuff like this it's like bro you
got 10 bodies it only takes one it only
takes one so at the end of the day don't
even be out there trying to throw shade
like that it's like you should be make
sure your sexual history is good yeah
just out of safety dude like keep track
March March March okay there you go I'm
just saying that's what I thought I was
like what the heck no no sorry it's no
people are people and not just numbers
obviously but I was just I'm just saying
like all right much better I got to keep
track in my head cuz I forget things all
the time yeah it was a little bit
dramatic for me um and that was coming
from the quiet guy so it was just kind
of confusing I didn't mean to impart any
judg upon him for that at all I was just
thinking like um it's like oh well I
mean duh dude everyone here thinks women
are people like I think that's we all
agree like no they're not just numbers
they're not like wins but if someone's
asking you the question I was thinking
like well what's the rough
answer maybe I but one is not one is
they ask about body
count and he's like oh women are just
you know women are not numbers and then
you went well how when's the last time
you got tested cuz yes they're not L we
just said keep track it doesn't mean
that he didn't keep
track he just didn't say he said I want
to keep that private here's the thing
I'm not mad at you get annoyed by him
like I don't want to see people's
numbers I want like okay shut the [__]
up all right you don't have to romanze
the whole thing okay but it's okay to
just say I keep that kind of stuff
private let's let's be honest when
people ask the body can question it
comes with judgment it's never neutral
if you say zero people judge you oh
you're a virgin right some people see
negative judgment with being a virgin
some people see it as a positive you got
a really low body count people ask why
is it because you couldn't get dates is
it because you weren't in a relationship
for a long time all these questions come
with judgment and the thing is when it
comes to sexual history just me
personally my personal life I've never
had women ask me about my body count I
think I had it happen one time and it
just turned out it was because the other
person was insecure about their own
sexual PR so they felt the need to ask
the question that was why right but like
the question doesn't come from nowhere
if you actually concerned about sexual
history get tested period now if you're
concerned about other things like hey
maybe you've had a very experience sex
just ask the question it's like are you
someone who's been very adventurous in
your sex life that's a reasonable
question body count is just so [__]
juvenile one two it gives you inaccurate
information that you're going to make
bad assumptions off of and three it just
it sounds like something teenagers ask
if you a grown ass person asking about
body G I'm going look at you a little
funny to be honest with you that
something like teenagers ask first of
Body Count how many bodies you count
we're using what murder and Hip-Hop
lingo to describe like how how many
people you slept with I remember when we
were growing up is what's your number
like the number of people you slept with
and then eventually I don't know when it
happened it became body count and the
first time someone asked that I remember
I watched the videos like some dude was
going around asking people their body
count and he went up to this one dude
hold up let me see so what's your body
count what's my what your body count my
oh no I don't do that like n I'm not
talking about like man need kill I'm
talking about like how many bit [__]
half half the state of Kansas when he
heard that he said he thought it was no
no no I I don't kill people I'm not
doing I'm not doing that oh we skipped
him oh oh oh okay you don't have to say
no I don't really care it's it's I don't
care uh like 27 28 okay 20 [__] ly
that's what you are hey 20 [__] lying
that's what you are hey hey he's what 23
hey it's okay you going lie and that's
also the other problem with the
questions like nobody believes you or
like or like they just don't have a
reason to it's like um damn if you do
damn if you don't absolutely um who pays
on the first date
oh yeah yeah I honestly who makes more
money I think it sometimes depends on
who invited who but most of the time
it's like in a heterosexual setting it's
like the guy inviting the girl so with
Andros I felt like he had Direction in
his life he just screamed provider man
mindset and that's something that I'm
very attracted to what do you feel like
is something that you struggle with the
most that you're like working towards
fixing that has prevented you from like
healthy
relationships I can say I lost myself at
one point in my life um just going
through a lot of hardships especially
with my grandma when she died I just
kind of lost myself in the I was lost
myself in the sauce I can definitely say
I was toxic to a certain gr a couple
years ago oh my God bro I don't know why
but I feel like this man just needs to
stay away from Jubilee and go to therapy
bro there's a lot of death going on with
him and it's come out in one episode
that's that's insane sorry but every
time this guy speaks it just sounds sad
doesn't it
yeah
violence I feel for him but God bless
him I think for me I tend to dedicate a
lot of time at work and so sometimes I
think my ex would say that I neglect
them or I don't spend enough time with
them and as I'm getting older I think
I'm realizing that you know having a
healthy relationship actually really
helps with your Ambitions you're an
Aries I'm an Aries yeah that makes
sense these people make me want to lose
it it's like a dude sharing something
insightful or very interesting and deep
about himself that's personal it's like
Earth sign yeah you know I want to just
be like one day guys just said like uh
yeah so you know I think for me it's
tough It's very difficult um to find
good work life balance cuz I'm very
invested in my work and it's made me in
the click my partners and so now as I
get older I think I'm realizing those
relationships are much more important
and uh I want to spend more time in them
and then the girls just like single
parent household yeah uh yeah no dad
around
yeah just I just just like I so like
misplaced like is everyone here single
yes yes for the most part
yeah she's going to watch no she knows
like we talk about this I'm I
communicate these things do you guys
believe in
monogamy to certain extent I think the
the way our generation is going marriage
is kind of dying out you don't need to
be married with somebody it's just like
someone that you trust and have a good
relationship with that you can build a
relationship and it's like I do believe
in like one person finding another
person and they can be together for as
long as that happens and then maybe one
day they break up or end things who
knows it happens it's realistic
this with his looks and his personality
and um his job definitely someone I'd
actually be interested in getting to
know outside of this I really didn't
agree with a lot of his views on stuff
which is fine like you do you it's just
not for me and then I was just like
mildly uncomfortable which is nothing
against
him yeah my number one has energy in
line with like men that I'm usually
attracted to oh no I knew it I knew I
knew it I knew that the dude cried twice
and they put him in fifth yeah that is
foul to be fair it's not like the only
negative quality he had he said he
didn't remember how many people he slept
with right cuz he wasn't keeping track
he also every answer was word soup so
word soup I'll get it so my number one
it's because he's giving a sense of
stability so it's giving like more daddy
Vibes and I really like
that I hate these people I'm sorry I I
hate I hate everybody on this goddamn
panel yes Daddy all right if a girl ever
told me yo I but you give Daddy Vibes
how be like listen I ain't adopting
[__] get the [__] up out of here that's
just not happening number four um I
really appreciated his honesty and
vulnerability so fifth we have West told
you at 7 he said told you he said told
you he said man I shouldn't have cried
yeah damn right you should have keep
your [__] tears to yourself
Hey listen and the girls went like they
didn't choose them
listen I'm not saying that men's tears
in hly turn the women off but if you
haven't built that kind of comfort and
relationship with them yeah you
shouldn't be crying in front of hey I'm
going say something else that's [__]
up too I think it's unsexy when a women
cry early too and then even a man or
woman they keep your [__] tears to
yourself until you really well in there
you got some personal
deep keep that [__] until you ENT the
reason being it's like
okay I'm going to say something [__]
up but I don't think it's that [__] up
is they value that [__] because it's
private and sacred but if you just doing
that in front of everybody on the first
time then they going to look at you
funny yeah they it's not it's not for
you that's it it's not [__] up at all
yeah it's not [__] up at all I went
the last time you cried I'm lying it was
when I was notching Naruto s years ago
I'm not telling them the truth they
don't need to know I just met these
people yo AB but what's your social ins
I'm not I don't need to tell them just
cuz it's a show I don't need to tell the
truth it's part I don't have to tell
everybody last time you C I don't know
you keep
track also I think keeping track of when
this last time you it's kind of
weird last time I cried was October
2021 and yeah you keep track no I don't
think they keep track like they have a
date it's just if you ask somebody they
think about the last time I imagine buts
in
fourth we have Kai yeah I told you I
told you what
Kai you had 13 points o love it in
third
Nick no
way at 15 points second Jack at 16
points like Mama we made it thank God
and in first Andros at 24 points 2 what
that's a lot You' be my top one thank
you why did you act surprised like they
already said every other number I hate
these people bro I don't know what it is
it's just some dislike you chose the
dude and you got surprise of the people
you chose you put them no because they
they they didn't know who the other
people chose so they're surprised by
everyone chose the same guy it's it's
okay I'm not mad at that I actually hate
the dudes more I think than the women I
do something about them just but maybe
I'm being unfair I don't know what it is
I really dislike this male cast
something about them just but what's
your thoughts both of them both of them
both of them all right I don't like well
there's a woman version of this so we
can watch it later it might be better we
never know maybe doubt it anyways let us
know what you guys think in the comments
I haed these people Payback